[موسيقى]
طبعا معظمنا تابع او سمع عن مؤتمر ابل
اللي اتعمل من ثلاث ايام بالضبط وده مؤتمر
سبتمبر الثانوي المخصص دايما للاعلان عن
الاجيال الجديده من منتج الشركه الاشهر
على الاطلاق الايفون والساعات واحيانا
منتجات تانيه بعد الاعلان عن ايفون 15
بنسخه المختلفه وتوضيح اهم مع اضافته
الشركه لنسخه
الجديده ايه 17 بتقنيه تلاته نانومتر
والجيل التاسع من قبل واتش واول ما خلص
المؤتمر كنت متاكد ان المشاكسات المعتاده
اللي مش بفهمها دايما دي ما بين مستخدمي
ابل مستخدمه تليفونات الاندرويد بكل
انواعها هتبدا فجهزت نفس للحفله وقلت هشوف
ايه اللي هيحصل المره دي لكن انطباعي ان
دي اول مره ما تكونش الخناقات بالشراسه
بتاعه كل سنه بس مش ده المهم عندي بصراحه
اللي انا مهتم به اكتر هو اقتصاد ابل
الضخم جدا جدا اللي بيعادل الاقتصاد دول
كامله اقتصاد الشركه اللي دخل في حرب
الدوله احتمال كبير ما تكونش قدها خالص
قبل يا اخواننا هي الشركه الوحيده على وجه
الارض لقيمتها السوقيه تعدت التلاته
تريليون دولار مرتين اول السنه اللي فاتت
واواخر يونيو اللي فات رقم مدهش بيعادل
تقريبا حجم سادس اكبر اقتصاد في العالم هو
الاقتصاد البريطاني سنه اللي فاتت 2022
وقابل لسه لحد لحظه تصوير الحلقه هي
الشركه الاكبر في العالم بقيمه سوقيه فوق
اتنين فاصل سبعه تريليون دولار يكفي تعرفه
ان الشركه في الثمان سنين اللي فاتوا مثلا
من 2015 ل 2022 وهي بتبيع من منتج واحد بس
من منتجاتها اللي هو الايفون فوق ال 200
مليون تليفون كل سنه ما عدا سنه 2019 اللي
باعت فيها عدد حزين وهو 191 مليون ايفون
بس متخيلين الارقام يا جماعه ده بيخلي ابل
ببساطه بتبيع ثمانيه من اكتر عشر تليفونات
مبيعا في العالم كل سنه وهي صاحبه اكتر
ثلاث انواع مبيعا السنه اللي فاتت ده غير
المنتجات التانيه الكتيره سواء هاردوير او
سوفت وير واللي كانت احدث اضافه ليها في
اول يونيو اللي فات نضاره الواقع الهجين
برو الاقتصاد المهول ده بقى دخل في حرب زي
ما هحكي لكم حرب لازم نركز فيها جدا مع
واحده من قوى العالم العظمى في الصين لو
بصينا على الحرب دي والامريكا والهند
اطراف فيها هنلاقي ان ابرز تجلي لها كان
من تسع ايام بالظبط وتحديدا يوم سته
سبتمبر لما صحيفه كشفت ان مجلس الدوله
الصيني امر المسؤولين في الوكالات
الحكوميه المركزيه بالامتناع عن استخدام
الايفون او اي تليفونات ثانيه علامتها
التجاريه اجنبيه ضمن الحمله الصينيه اللي
هنتكلم عنها بعد شويه فايه اللي خلى
الصينيين يبداوا يكشروا عن انيابهم
ويقلبوا الترابيزه على ابل وهل السن تقدر
تؤذي ابل ولا الشركه بقت اكبر من ان دوله
تاثر عليها باي شكل وليه ابل مت جهه بكل
قوتها ناحيه الهند وقابل نفسها رايحه على
فين ده جزء من الحندرش فيه مع بعض في حلقه
النهارده انا اشرف ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
اشكال الممكنه في ناس شايفه ان الشركه مش
هتكمل بالشكل ده للابد ومصيرها لانهيار
مستقبلا بعد ما تستنفذ مواردها وبما انها
توقفت عن ابداع الجديد من ساعه ما خرج
الايفون للنور والفريق ده شايف ان الشركه
قائمه على الايفون بس في فريق مش شايف ده
ورايو ان الشركه في اقوى حالاتها انا بقى
من الفريق اللي في النص اللي شايف ان
الشركه قويه وبدات تجدد وتطلع بره دايره
الايفون اللي بيحقق لها نص ارباحها
بالكامل سنويا لدوائر اوسع شويه لسه في
بدايتها وشايف ان مركز قوه الشركه الحقيقي
مش في اجهزتها وانما في بيئه انظمه
التشغيل المتناغمه اللي بتوفرها لاجهزتها
الحقيقه ده مش رايي لوحدي وانما كمان هو
راي فرصه اليوم واحد من مهندسي قبل
القدامى في 2013 وحاليا شغال مهندس رئيس
شركه تسلا فورست شايف ان ابل بتركز جدا او
قايمه بالكامل على اختراع وتطوير وصناعه
منتجات تبسطك كعميل انبساط عالي جدا مكيفك
قوي لدرجه انك هتبقى على استعداد تشتري
المنتج بسعر اعلى من قيمته الحقيقيه لانك
شايفه استحق وفورس تكمل ووصف ابل انها زي
مطعم غالي جدا وقدامه في السوق حد زي مج
انت ممكن تروح لماكدونالدز لان طعمه كويس
ومقبول وسريع ورخيص في نفس الوقت لكن لما
بتروح المطعم الغالي المبالغ فيه فانت
بتروح علشان تاخد اكتر تجربه طهي ممكن
الفلوس توفرها وتكون مدهشه وجديده بالنسبه
لك وصف فورست يا اخواننا انا شايفه صحيح
جدا الحقيقه ان فلسفه ابل بتقوم على
التطوير البطيء للوصول لمنتج فوري يقفل
السوق من قبل ما يتفتح دي الفلسفه
الاساسيه هناك بجانب طبعا التسعير المبالغ
فيه لمنتجات بتطور ببطء كل سنه التسعير ده
متعلق بالبرنده نفسه مش بتطور الاجهزه
التقنيه خاصه ان الناس بتحب ده وبتدفع فيه
وده واضح تماما في الايفون مثلا علشان كده
فورست في 2013 كان بيقول ان مستقبل مش
بيعتمد على قدرتها على صناعه منتجات شكلها
حلو ولها برستيج بس وانما بيعتمد على
قدرتها على انشاء منصه لافضل 10,000 مطور
مثلا في العالم علشان يوصلوا لعملاء جدد
باستمرار ويقدموا لهم كل الخدمات الممكنه
عن طريق التطبيقات من خلال بيئه مغلقه طب
هتقول لي ما ده كلام كويس يا عشري فين
المشكله بقى المشكله ان البنزين اللي
بيشغل قالت الاختراع والتطوير الضخمه دي
هو المبيعات الارباح الفلوس ببساطه ومصدر
الدخل الاساسي اللي هو الايفون بدا يرجع
بضهره لاول مره بشكل ظاهر جدا في التمن
سنين اللي فاتوا لو بصينا على مبيعات ابل
يا جماعه واربحها بنهايه 2022
هنلاقيها حققت اكثر من 205 مليار دولار من
مبيعات ايفون بمختلف طرازاته وده حوالي
52% من صافي مبيعاتها في السنه بعد كده
تيجي خدماتها ودي بتتضمن انظمه التشغيل
والافلام والالعاب والموسيقى وغيرها
بتاعتها منها وصلت لاكتر من 78 مليار
دولار بعد كده تيجي الاكسسوارات بمختلف
انواعها ومبيعاتها عده 41 مليار دولار ثم
بعد كده مبيعات حواسيب ابل الشهيره ماك ب
40 مليار دولار بعدهم تيجي مبيعات اجهزه
الايباد باكتر من 29 مليار دولار اللي
بيحصل ان مبيعات الايفون نسبتها في مبيعات
الشركه اعلى بمراحل من منتجات الشركه
التانيه ودي ظاهره غير صحيه وده هياخدنا
للتلات نقط اللي بداوا يعملوا ازمه الابل
في الفتره الاخيره من ناحيه الايفون
تحديدا التلاته دول هم مبيعات السنه دي
2023 والحظر الصيني وشركه واو ابل في
الربع التاني من السنه دي مثلا قلت
مبيعاتها من الايفون بنسبه 9.3% مقارنه
بنفس الفتره من السنه اللي فاتت 2022 ده
اكبر انخفاض مبيعات ايفون في الثمان سنين
اللي فاتوا وتناقص المبيعات ده والظاهره
خاصه بربع التاني بس وانما زي ما قلنا
ظاهره عامه السنه دي بالنسبه لابل لو
ركزنا اكتر هنلاقيها ظاهره ممتده لسوق
الهواتف المحموله العالمي كله في حاله من
التشبع بين المستهلكين فطبيعي الحاله دي
اول ما هتمسك في حد هتمسك في اكبر منتج في
العالم النقطه التانيه متعلقه بالحظر
الصيني والصراع اللي بوادره ظهرت بين
الحكومه المركزيه الصينيه وشركه ابل واللي
اثر على القيمه السوقيه للشركه مع العوامل
التانيه فكل ده مسح باستيكه 310 مليار
دولار من القيمه السوقيه القصوى لشركه ابل
واللي وصلت لتلاته فاصل واحد تريليون
دولار في اواخر يوليو اللي فات فالحظر
الصيني ده هنحتاج نرجع فيه بالوقت لوراء
شويه قبل من سنين ولحد اول الشهر ده ممكن
نوصفها بانها ابرز الناجين من المذبحه
يعني ايه يعني هي واحده من ابرز الشركات
الامريكيه والصينيه اللي ناجت من مدافع
اقوى اقتصادين في العالم واللي حاطينها
بقى لهم فتره طويله في وش بعض وبشكل خاص
امريكا اللي صعدت ح التجاريه مع الصينيين
لمستويات غير مسبوقه من الضغط والحظر
والحصار التجاري في وسط كل ده قبل كملت
عادي لانها ببساطه بتمثل ثقل لا يستهان به
في الاقتصاد المحلي الصيني مع توفيرها
لملايين الوظائف المباشره وغير المباشره
وقوتها في السوق هناك الحاجه التانيه اللي
خلت تبقى على الجانب الجيد والمرضي عنه من
الصينيين انها على مر السنين امثلت
للقوانين الصينيه الصارمه الخاصه بالحريات
الرقميه وازالت الاف التطبيقات من متجرها
الرقمي لما كان الصينيين بيشاوروا عليها
ويقولوا انها غير قانونيه باي شكل قبل
برضو هي البائع رقم واحد في الصين
للموبايلات البريميا يعني الموبايلات
الغاليه اللي سعرها بيبدا من 600 ل 700
دولار وطالع واللي اداها مساحه اكبر طبعا
الفرم اللي فرمته امريكا شركه واوي كم سنه
اللي فاتوا بمختلف الاشكال لكن يبدو ان
شهر العسل ده انتهى بعد الحظر الصيني
لاستخدام مسئوليها الحكوميين لهواتف
الشركه ومنتجعتها لو ركزنا مع الصينيين
شويه هنلاقي ان الحظر ده مش اول مره يطبقه
على الايفون وانما بقى لهم سنين بيمنعوا
مسئولي بعض الوكالات الامنيه
والاستخباراتيه وبعض الادارات من استخدام
هواتف الشركه الامريكيه او اي هواتف
اجنبيه عموما لكن اللي حصل الايام اللي
فاتت انهم وسعوا الدايره دي علشان تشمل كل
المسؤولين في كل الادارات تقريبا الحمله
الصينيه دي مش خاصه بقابل منتجاتها بس
يعني لو شفنا اللي بيحصل بشكل اوسع فدي مش
اول مره الصينيين يمنعوا مسؤوليهم من
استخدام منتجات شركه امريكيه تقنيه عملاقه
عملوها قبل كده في 2021 مع شركه تسلا ثالث
اكبر باقي على السيارات الكهربائيه في
الصين ساعتها مجلس الدوله قلل المسؤولين
العسكريين وموظفي الشركات الرسميه
المملوكه للدوله يا جماعه ممنوع تستخدمه
عربيات تسلا علشان خايفين اللي هيحصل
اختراق للامن القومي باي شكل من خلال حزم
البيانات الضخمه اللي بتجمعها عربيات تسلا
طول الوقت الحمله الصينيه دي لاستبدال
التكنولوجيا الاجنبيه بتكنولوجيا محليه
اسمها
والحمله دي مش وليده اللحظه لكن الصينيين
بداوها لما كشف في مجموعه من تسريباته سنه
2013 نوكاله الامن القومي الامريكيه
اخترقت شبكات الحواسيب الصينيه وبتتجسس
عليها لكن تاريخ ابل في مسائل الخصوصيه
والامان مع الصينيين كويس جدا عكس شركات
وجهات امريكيه تانيه كتير ومن اشهر الادله
على ده لما من كم سنه اثارت بكين ان مراكز
تجميع البيانات من الصينيين اللي
بيستخدموا اجهزه ابل لازم تكون على
الاراضي الصينيه مش الامريكيه وقابل
استجابت للطلب الصيني بالفعل وبنت مراكزها
هناك بس واضح ان الصينيين بداوا يجيبوا
اخرهم الامريكان بمختلف الاشكال وده امتد
لعلاقتهم بابل ودعمهم لواوي في مواجهه
واشنطن لحد ما وصلنا لاعلان واول مفاجئ عن
تليفونها الجديد اللي بيدعم تقنيات شبكات
الخامس واللي يبدو ان الصينيين صنعوا
معالجه المتقدم محليه في سابقا خليه
الامريكان مرعوبين النقطه التانيه في
ترجيح الشخصي اللي مخليه الصين بدات تضايق
ابل هو اتجاه ابل في الكم سنه اللي فاته
ناحيه الهند قبل 14 سنه اللي فاتت ما كانش
بيتم غير جزء صغير جدا من عمليه تجميع
هواتف الايفون في الهند الجزء ده كان
بيتصدر بعد الاجهزه المصنعه والمجمعه في
الصين بشهور طويله لكن ده تغير السنه اللي
فاتت لما الهند بدات تقرب من امريكا على
خلفيه توتراتها الضخمه مع الصين بسبب
المشاكل الحدوديه وتغير برضو بسبب سعي
الهند الحسيس انها تبقى مركز تصنيع عملاق
في اسيا ينافس الصين خاصه في تصنيع
المنتجات الامريكيه والاوروبيه وده اللي
حصل بالفعل ولو بصينا على اللي حصل هنلاقي
ان فجوه التاخير دي بين الايفون الصيني
والهندي قلت وقبل اشتغلت على انها ترفع
نسبه الايفون الهندي لحد ما وصلت في نهايه
مارس اللي فات لتصنيع في الميه من الانتاج
العالمي للايفون في الهند وحاليا مع صدور
ايفون 15 وللمره الاولى هنلاقي هواتف
صناعه هنديه بتتشحن للمستهلكين مع الشحنه
الاولى من تليفون ابل الجديد فيبدو ان خطه
ابل بتنجح فعلا في انها تقلل من اعتمادها
على الصين في التصنيع والتوريد ضمن خطتها
لتنوع اماكن التصنيع دي في السنين الجايه
وده بطبيعه الحال مش هيكون كويس في نظر
النظام الصيني اللي عاوز يستحوس على معظم
ماكينه التصنيع الاسيويه عنده الصينيين
بيفتخروا دايما انهم مصنع العالم لكن يبدو
ان ده بدا يتغير ولو ببطء عليه لكن على
الاقل في الوقت الحالي فصين ما تقدرش تاذي
ابل زي ما امريكا مثلا عملت في واول كم
سنه اللي فاتوا لحد ما الشركه الصينيه
رجعت فجاهتنا كلنا طب ليه لان ابل وعلى
عكس هواوي متغلغله في الاقتصاد الصيني
واقتصاد منتجاتها المهول ده هو مورد مالي
للحكومه الصينيه وعلاقات مع اكبر شركه في
والاهم هو انه بيعزز من الاقتصاد المحلي
من خلال توفير فرص عمل مباشره وغير مباشره
للصينيين وبعض الشركات المحليه برضو ده
كله يخلي محاوله اقتلاع ابل بنفس الكتالوج
بتاع امريكا مع هواوي هو خيار صعب جدا لكن
اظن ان الصين هتحاول تحجم وجود ابل وتخليه
اقل مساحه في الكم سنه جايين زي ما قبل
بتحاول تعمل حاليا كده برضو فده اتجاه
اعمال يبدو من الطرفين متفقين عليه بشكل
ضمني اما بالنسبه لابل نفسها فباختصار انا
شايف ان الشركه لو ما خرجتش منتج جديد
للنور يكون طفر تكنولوجيه يعيد تعريف
الشركه في عيون المستهلكين وفي نفس الوقت
يكون مصدر دخل بينمو باستمرار وتاريخ
صلاحيته طويل لو ما عملتش ده فغالبا تناقص
الارباح والقيمه السوقيه ده هيفضل مستمر
وقد يفضي في السنوات الجايه مع تشبع السوق
اكتر واشتداد المنافسه لنتايج اسوا لاكبر
شركه في العالم المنتج ده لا باس به من
الناس بيتوقع انه هيبقى نظاره
وفريق تاني بيتوقع انه هيكون ايفون جديد
بامكانيات مختلفه وجديده تماما لكنها تحت
التطوير دلوقتي وفريق تالت بيتوقع ان
المنتج موجود بالفعل هو حواسب الماك واللي
قطاع عريض من مستخدمين بيعتبرها افضل
حواسيب محموله في العالم لكن المنتج ده
محتاج ضخ فلوس اكتر خاصه والمنافسه في سوق
الحواسيب اصعب بكتير من سوق الهواتف
المحموله العالمي وفي فريق رابع بيتبنى
الاشاعات المنتشره ان ابل بتخطط لانهاء
انتاج الايفون تماما واستبداله بمنتج
مختلف مش عاوز اطول عليكم اكتر من كده
ولحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي قلنا بس نعمل
حلقه سريعه نسلط بها الضوء باختصار على
اخر تطورات شركه ابل كلها بعد المؤتمر
وكالعاده في النهايه عندي سؤال لحضراتكم
تفتكروا قبل هتستمر على قمه هرم شركات
التكنولوجيا العالميه ولا الشركه بدات
مسار الانهيار او على الاقل هترجع تبقى
شركه عاديه فتابع كل اجاباتكم في
التعليقات اللي عايز يشتري اسهم او ذهب ما
تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت
الفيديو في نهايه
وشير واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم
عننا يمكن يستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]